when the United Kingdom
started supporting Ukraine to resist Russia's invasion
Putin called Boris Johnson
who was the prime minister of the UK at the time
and told him
I don't wanna hurt you
but with a missile
it will only take a minute
according to Boris Johnson
Putin was speaking in such a calm manner
as if he were playing a video game
and was about to press a button to launch the missile
if this had happened
the UK would have immediately responded
with a nuclear missile strike
prompting Russia to retaliate with a nuclear bomb
this scenario would have likely
triggered a response from every other NATO country
due to Article 5 of NATO
which obliges the US and other NATO members to
engage in a collective defense against
any attack on a NATO member
do you think Putin should have pressed on that button